so when i was younger i had i had like a
thing where stuff from my body fell into
my balls what this is true
all right ryan long answering the
internet
if you saw that one of your friends
accidentally posted a dick pic on
snapchat would you tell him or let him
leave it up i would screenshot for sure
i would tell him but like there'd be
repercussions still
but the repercussions we deal with that
internally
you know what i mean you have to you
have to deal with your bodies internally
but you i'm not going to you can't put
them on blast to the world
the crew isn't going to know for sure
but yeah
yeah exactly team meeting you go what
are the repercussions if someone texted
you a picture of your dick with no
context would you know it's your dick
that's a good question i tattooed mine
black so i would that's one of the
reasons i'm always
uh don't like to do stuff like that it's
because i have all the tattoos so it's
pretty obvious it's me yeah so i think
hard
no flaccid no i no no flaccid yes
because my balls are too big
dude i just i'm not kidding so when i
was younger i had i had like a thing
where stuff from my body fell into my
balls
this is true so i went to the doctor and
you know
[Laughter]
so i had to get the surgery and what
they do is stuff like your intestines
like your brain maybe
stuff i don't know they don't tell you
the technical that's the the
the scans up on the window things see
the stuff stop it
you got way
yeah it's a technical term whatever's in
there some more yeah and once in a while
it would look normal but most of the
time it's not good because flaccid it
makes your dick look bad right
and you know it's like oh you got a
small dick it's like my big you know
no
yeah compared to these [ __ ] mountains
ryan's gotta hang upside down before
sending the dick pic just to get all
this
stuff
put ice on ice in the dude it used to be
a thing where like i'm not kidding i was
at the gym once and it like came out my
shoulder like it's a ish it's like
[ __ ] johnny knoxville when he's doing
the thing right
so the best is i get this surgery and
they go we put like they basically said
it's like a dam so we're going to cut
the blood flow off they put copper in
your thing
and then so it was it worked for two
days and then they got big and again and
i went to the doctor he goes didn't take
like
he stopped his stuff can't be stopped
it couldn't be stopped so
we could try again like all right
so if it was if the balls were heavily
featured i might be like i know
if you were murdered who would be the
most likely suspect that would be yeah
that would definitely be mother and
father because kind of like what we were
saying before they
let me know that this was not supposed
to happen but we will make do
so she you know little notes in my
backpack lunch like this was supposed to
be for someone else a girl
that was just a pain laughter yeah they
tried to put the wig on me and they go
we'll make you a girl and i go it's not
working there and you know hit a gross
bird that really wasn't happy for them
not a good time for the parents would
you rather cure cancer prove aliens are
real or prove ghosts are real you know
what cure cancer is the only one that
anyone would believe you i mean how many
people think that they're proving aliens
are real right now if you right now you
came out with your youtube channel with
the alien head everyone be like this
[ __ ] alex jones [ __ ] get the
hell out of here no one wants to hear
this [ __ ] and ghosts you're gonna be the
guy like no listen to my sonar readings
look at my machine
i for no one's believing you
no i've got him in my basement everyone
goes you know tommy i think it's time
for you to
take a nap
the cia right now is like not for real
it's true they go shut the [ __ ] up cia
shut up would you [ __ ] the ugliest
teacher you've ever had to be able to
[ __ ] the hottest teacher i've ever had i
don't even need the second half of the
question i [ __ ] the ugliest teacher like
for the joke
maybe i [ __ ] know if i should say it
okay i'm not going to say her real name
because maybe it's me but there was
let's just say her name was miss tiger
so we had a thing where she would she
had this drama class and for every day
me and my buddies one of us would run by
and go
tiger
it was for whatever reason this started
and to the point where like everyone
would try to go to the bathroom and it
became this like game how many and she
goes she'd run out i know who's doing
that you know whatever but if i could go
back to my buddies and be like yo just
[ __ ] tiger and be like
are you kidding me guess what aza was
leaving yelp
as you're coming you yell that
thank you it was you
dude [ __ ] a gross teacher be
hilarious
[ __ ] hottest teacher is like
okay
mr cool guy i [ __ ] the hottest teacher
at our school mr jefferson
why
why you said honest i'm not gay he's the
hottest teacher he's objectively the
hottest teacher because of fire oh okay
he's a sunshine man that's canadian i
gave you a canadian reference i was like
you know how you have the bar still
girls
it was like we had this thing sunshine
girls but there was a guy too
much less play on that
[Laughter]
would you have sex with a girl with no
arms yeah you would definitely
have sex with no girl girl with no arms
but you'd want her to take them off
herself because you know what i mean i
wouldn't want to be the part of the
undressing i wouldn't want to
because that would get awkward you know
what i mean you're trying to put the
condom on you know you start fiddling
with the arms do you think in the
morning you [ __ ] a girl with no arms and
when they're like nah they leave their
purse there or some [ __ ] like that
yeah hey lady
not falling for that i'm sorry
trying to play you oh come on you think
i'm born yesterday all right
you got me it definitely feels weird
when i put them in my trophy case
next to some real arms and it's
no this is not i just do this anymore i
do this to anyone
well you don't like my fake arms i do i
always do this
it's nothing to do it's not personal if
you were in an open field with an
aluminum baseball bat how many 10
how many 10 year olds with bike helmets
could you take down before they got you
so i actually did this experiment
it's not about how many could you take
down it's how many there are if there's
unlimited one at a time so you're not
going to get like world war z zombies
are there on you it's just well i guess
if you can't now are these like 1940 10
year olds or like new my peanuts you
know 10 year old
because if
a new type of ten-year-old you just pull
out a jar of peanut butter
old-school ten-year-olds they got
switchblades they were in a coal mine
those guys will take you down the first
one you hit with a bike how many [ __ ]
gets back up that's all you got yo what
the dad does that every night yes spits
out his chew
i'm taking my kid home you got a kid
would you stop masturbating if every
girl you jerked off to
knew you were doing it you'd have to go
anime almost at that point you got to
beat the system yeah you go fake but i
think that that point your ex-girlfriend
gets a notification well tell you what
because you guys are in entertainment
and stuff like that like you know what i
mean if even if you're a normal guy
like some porn star gets a notification
or whatever like jim at [ __ ] walmart
jerked off to me who gives a [ __ ] but if
it's you like and it's just like again
the fifth time today six in the morning
it's funny you like she sees you doing
something like you see a president he's
doing like a live press briefing he goes
actually just need to go to the bathroom
really quick oh come on
get it together biden hi today yeah yeah
he's at the funeral and so i think it's
9 11. yeah
that was uh i think that was a louis
joke maybe how long would you wait after
9 11 like
but i think yeah it's like i think that
if you were
if you're popular you have to be a
little more sparing you almost have to
pay girls to jerk off to them like hush
money
like 100 bucks what's this for just
listen
[Laughter]
would you punch your grandma in the face
to [ __ ] the girl of your dreams well i
don't want to punch a girl i don't want
to then i have to [ __ ] a girl who's been
punched in the face
okay so would i punch a girl in the face
to [ __ ] if she's grandma no you can't
well she would know then she'd be like
i'd be like you know what i did i do i
crossed mountains for you what
specifically let's not get into
specifics about what i did for this
let's just say i'm here
anyways if you want to start do you want
to start shall we start
what's that blood from
[Laughter]
does it bother you if a girl you're
dating makes more money than you i only
think it bothers you because if you
still have to pay for everything that's
the you know you're dating because then
you go
you're paying for everything and then
also she's like just putting money in
[ __ ] crypto
you're like well we'll go 50 50. he's
like what am i a [ __ ] dude now to be
completely honest though i don't find a
lot of 18 year olds that make more money
than me
[Laughter]
i've dated girls that had more money
than me but didn't make it yeah you know
what i mean like they had money for and
those girls are tough because you can't
even impress them with you know you mean
you bring them to a 500 dinner or some
[ __ ] and they go yeah i mean like as
well yeah yeah exactly and you're like
we shouldn't have
would you rather change genders every
time you sneeze
necessarily would you rather change
genders every time you sneeze or not be
able to tell the difference between a
donut and a baby
i guess that would be yeah bad if you
end up [ __ ] a donut
[Laughter]
either way but that you don't even know
which one i tried to find
all right
directions are [ __ ] fun
right i'm laughing every topic i mean
you'd have to do that and you go yeah
i'm staying away like
what's the alternative i guess if you
have a baby i didn't even think of that
one because i was like just stay the
[ __ ] away from babies and then you're
like i remember my answer changed yeah
then you have a kid here i love donuts i
was like [ __ ] yeah yeah next thing you
know you're eating your
kids i think it would be great to just
no but you still you still have to do
that one i think
as long as you can sneeze on on command
you don't want to get stuck dude i need
something to jerk off dude
mental pitcher
but yeah your kid's like oh daddy you
never even paid attention to me for the
first three years you're like you were a
donut
i don't literally didn't even talk yeah
you're a donut
how much money would it take to be
verbally to verbally belittle a [ __ ]
in front of a crowd of 100 people what's
the race
[Laughter]
race and gender girl if it's like white
male [ __ ] i think i would you know we
can find a number but like if it was
like black like female crippled [ __ ] i
don't think i'd do it
we'd have to be like leave the country
money i don't need that smoke
white male [ __ ] like cocky you know
what i mean
yeah yeah dude he looks like me
they go they know each other
yeah you got tattoos on you got aviators
and [ __ ] you go all right people will be
looking at like what did the [ __ ] do
thank you for watching answer the
internet with ryan long please remember
to subscribe to the channel
set reminders with a little bell comment
who you want to see do it and watch all
the other answer the internets i don't
know where anything is so i'm kind of
moving my hands around but do all that
[ __ ] subscribe comment reminder watch
others you're welcome don't know why but
you're welcome